لو ان توظفوا الاراضي السوريه واجهه
لانظمها الصاروخيه والهجمات الاسرائيليه
الاخيره على سوريا كان الهدف منها ابشال
مشروع ايراني جوي في سوريا فما هي اسرار
هذا المشروع الذي اثارت اسرائيل على
التصدي له بكل حزم صحيفه نيوز ويك خاضت
بشكل دقيق في تفاصيل الموضوع من خلال
تقرير مفصل تقول الصحيفه ان الامر يتعلق
بمشروع مشترك بين ايران وقوات النظام
السوري في هدفه زرع نظام ايراني مستقل
للدفاع الجوي من داخل سوريا وهو المشروع
الذي صرفت من اجله عشرات الملايين من
الدولارات والهدف منه التعامل مع الضربات
الجويه الاسرائيليه
وتعود فكره هذا المشروع الاتفاق العسكري
الموسع عنا توصل اليه كبار ومسؤوليه
الدفاع من البلدين في يوليو 2020 اتفاق
تعاهد على اثره رئيس اركان الجيش الايراني
محمد باقري بان تقوي طهران منظومه الدفاع
الجوي السوريه في اطار تعزيز العلاقات
العسكريه بين البلدين
ويقوم المشروع الايراني على انشاء منصات
للصواريخ ووضع اجهزه رادار متطوره
باستخدام احدث الاسلحه الايرانيه ياتي في
مقدمتها صاروخ صياد بيفور الايراني الذي
يعمل بالوقود الصلب والذي تم الكشف عنه في
نوفمبر الماضي وتم اقرار قذفته صاروخ
الصياد بنظام صواريخ ارض جو
386 ميلا كما ان رادارها المضاد للطائرات
يغطي دائره يزيد قطرها عن 2008
المشروع الجوي الايراني في سوريا اشرف
عليه ابرز الخبراء الايرانيين والذين
كانوا هدفا للغارات الجويه الاسرائيليه
على امتداد السنوات الماضيه ياتي على
راسهم العقيد داو جعفر القائد في قوه
الفضاء الجوي في الحرس الثوري الايرانيه
والذي تقول المصادر الصحفيه انه قائد
مشروع الدفاع الجوي الايراني في سوريا
وكانت ايران نسبه مقتل جعفر الى قصف على
جانب الطريق في دمشق نفذته اسرائيل
اسرائيل من جهتها اختارت التصدي لتهديد
الايراني القادمه من سوريا مستهدفه
مشروعها الجوي من خلال غارات بدات اذا من
سنه 2017 وكانت المطارات وهدفا اساسيا
لهذه الغاره اهمها مطار دمشق الذي تعرض
لسبع غارات اسرائيليه خلال العام الماضي
وحده كذلك الغارات الاسرائيليه استهدفت
ايضا مطار حلب والذي كانت تستخدمه ايران
كقاعده عسكريه وفق تقارير اسرائيليه ومن
بين المطارات التي استهدفت من قبل اسرائيل
ايضا مطار دير الزور العسكري الذي تستخدمه
كل من ايران وروسيا كنقطه مرور لشحنات
الاسلحه والجنود